okay so welcome to another computer
musing and I hope that you people enjoy
seeing work in progress as much as as
I'm having fun doing this work well what
I want to show you today is done with
the help of two wonderful students well
I might as well introduce them right
away Robert Bosch and Chris Dorothy
Robert and Chris so you stand up we're
going to take anyway well I was going to
have to come here and fix it these are
what I say work in progress I mean that
that these guys haven't had any sleep
for the last three days and and oh and
we built the system that you're seeing
demoed now about a half an hour ago and
we've been you know making great
improvements to it all the last the last
several days and it's fantastic to work
with these guys I never known through
people before we could sit in the same
office and and and and both work
simultaneously on the same program and
and and and perfectly reinforce each
other and get stuff done fast we make a
we get an idea in NSA it's implemented a
few minutes later um so three weeks ago
I talked to you about M mix the this
this this nice clean RISC machine that
I've been playing with and I and
intending to use in in the next edition
of my books and today I want to show you
the these the simulators that were
building to to test out the ideas and
check them last Thursday and Friday
I'm sorry nice Friday and Saturday I
designed and and sketched out the
program for the assembler for M mix and
on set on Sunday I I did the the
programs that would that would simulate
the multiplication and division and then
Monday Tuesday and today we've been
working on this on this part of the
simulator right I started working on
this on the pipeline cinema goat
simulator actually though a long time
ago
in November and and it's it's I would
have to say it's one of the most
interesting programs I've ever had the
pleasure of working on this are the idea
and I wanted to explain about pipelines
today but this is a program that that
has very interesting complexities the
way the way computers in your parts of
computer interact with each other and I
want to show you some of the reasons why
I think the way I think they're they're
neat
the program itself isn't finished but I
can show you that the main part of it
can we maybe get this on the screen you
camera pick this up for you have to move
it over here you can zoom in so this
this is the table of contents for the
main part of the program and it's just
you know I like to write in C web
can you see see that a little bit so you
know in introduction low-level routines
proteins list dynamic speculation
dispatching execution commissioned the
issue of branch prediction cache memory
simulated memory cash transfers virtual
address translation the right back for
loading and storing fetch stage
interrupts administrative operations you
could probably bring down the house
lights and more register to register ops
expect for later that's what I haven't
written yet and so on now this this this
program has has enough complexity to it
that that I personally think that there
was no way that I could ever written
this without a tool like see web this
this idea of literate programming has
now in some ways a program this this
complex I've got it like if if if I
could ever have gotten anything like it
with this complexity working and
understand our understandable fashion if
I hadn't used this this way now like I
say a little bit about literate
programming because that you know in
literally
you you uh you try to write for human
beings to read the program and not just
for the computer to to understand the
program and then and I'm hoping that
some of you in the audience will enjoy
reading this someday because I plan to
put this into a book this book called M
mix where and let me read you first but
something about pipelines coming from
the introduction it says one way to
visualize the procedure of pipelines to
imagine that somebody has organized a
high-tech car repair shop according to
similar principles look it's a similar
to a computer there are eight
independent functional units in this car
repair shop we can think of them as
eight groups of auto mechanics each
specializing in a particular task each
group has its own workspace with room to
deal with one car at a time Group F the
first group is in charge of rounding up
customers and getting them to enter the
assembly line garage in orderly fashion
Group D the D code and despatch group
does the initial vehicle inspection
lights up an order that explains what
kind of servicing is required the
vehicles go next to one of for execution
groups Group X handles routine
maintenance groups X F X m and XD are
specialists in more complex tasks that
tend to take longer the X F group the X
F people are good at floating the points
while the X M + XD groups are experts in
multi-link suspension Xin differentials
when the relevant X group has finished
its work cars drive to M station where
they send or receive messages and
possibly pay money to members of the
memory group finally all necessary parts
are installed by members of group W the
right group in the car leaves the shop
everything is tightly organized so in
most cases the cars move in synchronized
fashion from station to station at
regular 100 nano century intervals
now-now-now this is the this is very
much the way a computer pipeline works
and let me show you a little bit of this
demo first by starting in the middle of
it
it's a program that I'll explain to you
a little more as time goes on but let me
first just go to a sort of a steady
state part of it whoops I got it hit the
control thing here so let me just go
it's a program that that calculates half
of a decimal integer it starts with one
and then it gets 1/2 1/4 1/8 1/16 and
works in decimal and as it's writing the
answer here you see it in the right
buffer a little on the left there it's
it's written in in ascii code so 30 is a
0 30 30 30 37 38 31 32 35 would be 0 0 0
7 8 1 2 5 which is some negative power
to it or at least maybe maybe somewhere
in the middle of the other step you can
sort of see these so the there's some
pulses in here that chickens that you
can see the vertical lines mean that
we've actually written a character to
the right buffer and then when there's a
little gap between that means we've
actually finished power to know here we
computed half of the previous one then
another half and another half another
half and so on and so now we're in the
middle of character of taking half of
the thing that we got on that cycle so
now there's you can see that there are
two instructions in the pipeline right
now one is it's like mu1 at the top in
the in in ALU one it's up here and then
there's another instruction the green
one here in the load store unit LS you
want now there's nothing here over here
is is the is the F group the fetch
buffer this is where instructions first
come before they're executed it happens
to be empty at the moment I'm not sure
why but it's it might be a bug but I
don't know and I think it's probably
okay and yeah it's because this
instruction in the ALU here says
probable branch if if a non zero and so
since it was it was a branch a probable
branch then now we cleared the fetch
buffers in assuming that the branch
would be taken and we and we're trying
to get the instructor you know we we
have to get instructions from another
place so we're branching that's why the
fetch buffer is is empty at this point
where we're loading a
this is an LDB instruction so we're
loading a bite into some register and
and so this these are the execution
units in this particular in this
particular version we we have two ALU
two arithmetic logical units and three
lost Orion and saw the particular
program isn't using them I believe it
would yeah we've run exactly as fast if
we had only one ALU and one LSU but but
the simulator that one of the things
that makes the simulator interesting is
that it is infinitely configurable I can
I can change I can say I have any number
of of units of any cut of any kind I can
say any any subset of M mixes op
operation towards and say that today I
have a functional unit that can
implement this and I can have as many of
these as I want for example and there's
many other ways to describe the or the
simulator each of these pop easily each
of these ways would be a conceivable way
perhaps to build to build a real image
machine now so instructions are first
fetched and then they're dispatched into
one of the execution units and then
after that after they're done executing
then they go here and this is called the
reorder buffer and the the technique
that we're using in in this pipeline
simulator is that is a it's because
dynamic scheduling with speculative
execution I'll talk more about what that
means but but essentially it says that
the the the computer decides as it as
things come out of the fetch buffer
which execution units should take them
and then and it'll also start executing
instructions ahead of time before you
know they're really needed and then as
some instructions take longer than
others for example a division takes 60
cycles as long as instruction in a mix
multiplication takes ten cycles
dad takes one cycle and so sometimes you
know instructions have to wait because
they depend on each other and here in
the reorder buffer we have one
instruction here it says inkle this is a
increase the lower white of other of a
register and it's it's ready to it it's
finished but the other two are grayed
out which means that they're that
they're waiting one of them's waiting
for this one one's waiting for this and
these instructions the instructions will
leave the reorder buffer in the same
order in which in which they exited they
entered and so I let me just run one one
step to show you what will happen on the
next cycle okay do you see do you see
that you want to see it backward go back
again so so this is where we were no no
no that was cycle six cycles 679 no that
was okay let's go forward to now so
here's the probable branch going going
on in there and then the two things are
going into the your order buffer maybe I
should stop it and and so you see these
the instructions play a little dance as
as they as they're going through the
machine now we've got two things in the
fetch buffer a load this is a load byte
and an ink pink L and then the load
store unit here has is a store byte
instruction was going to it's going to
store a byte in the right buffer and the
first and this is a two stations process
the first time one cycle it has to
figure out which byte tough you know the
virtual address that is going to store
into and on the next cycle it'll
actually do the storing these things
will complete and go into the output on
the next cycle this is waiting for the
store to to finish that from the fetch
buffer we should be able to get
the Intel instruction into an ALU at
this point in the and I think the star
bite is going to go into the second
stage no it didn't go yeah yeah the
story bite when to the second stage but
the load bite went into the to the
second load store unit in this case now
if I had only one load store unit would
have gone into the first one but it's
but since there are two it's safer to go
into the second because you never know
the first one might stall in the second
stage because because it you know if you
can't find that it can't find the data
in the cache cache might be busy or
something so so that's now now I it was
serendipity that I happen to run into in
demand all on the steps like a couple
months ago and he said he had two
students who were doing research on how
to visualize pipelines and that's how
come I met Robert and Chris and they and
they have they had been making such
visualizations for for real computers
look like but like the nips 10k machines
on and and it's amazing when you have a
tool like this for visualization how how
much easier it is to understand what's
going on to find bottlenecks and to see
what things work and what things don't
work so this is the but now I ideally we
would like to issue one instruction with
this particular machine it's it is set
up so that it issued one instruction
every cycle at most in it and it's a and
it and all of the reorder buffer commits
one instruction per cycle at most we can
also configure the simulator so that
it's superscalar which means that it'll
that it will allow several instructions
to be to be committed at a time in kill
going to execution and several
instructions to be to be to be issued at
a time stable to be committed I talked a
little bit about terminology here I find
out that when the students were talking
about what happens to instructions when
they leave the reorder buffer they said
they graduated
although a Johnny and John's bookie so
he calls it committed well yeah I guess
I can see why graduation is so important
to it but I but the other fun the other
thing I learned was that the students
their natural inclination was to put
things in the up and the other order
they had they had things at the bottom
of the reorder buffer and sort of and
sort of falling out at the bottom and
similarly a fetch buffer they were
coming in from the top and dropping down
and sort of sinking down and I don't
know that not my model of students it
seems to me that that students are
rising in until they finally when they
when they graduate they aren't settling
out they're actually you know going up
to the next level but anyway maybe this
is just a difference of generation gap
or difference between the way people
think on the third floor and forth well
but I insisted that they put ok anyway
but these instructions now appear as
they would in a program so as you write
this and you know as you write this
program you have an increase L load byte
print probable branch and and they
appear in that same order here and
similarly in the reorder buffer they
appear in the way they'll appear on 18
your coding form so that it had to be
that way for me
now this little strip chart on the
bottom shows the shows every every cycle
of this others of this demo in a
condensed form and so it'll show you the
reorder buffer but the things are sorted
by color so things that belong to the
ALU are this like I just like blue color
and and a darker green color are the
things from the store from the store
book i and there's interesting things
going on here you see these waterfalls
and mountains at the left and I'll talk
about that later
but the but we have exactly 2009 clock
cycles are shown here
you know we figured it was probably
dangerous to go beyond 2000 everybody
knows that that's a hard number
to pass hope so we stopped there but
stuff but this this program I'll show
you actually does go on and on it keeps
on in fact it never stops tonight but I
could run it now okay any questions
about this no questions
oh maybe I didn't explain it well enough
okay so now let me show you what they
good so it let me show you the program
that is that is executing and something
something about it so let me see that
step okay so now I'll show you that that
program that we're taking hands so this
is a program that that well I won't draw
but this is the this is a draft of the
assembly language bread mixer and it and
the program that we're actually running
here let's see how do i so it's a very
short program that that has this it has
this little loop here you jumps into the
middle of the loop and then the loop is
so nine instructions eight seven
instructions long and and and it's
ending with this probable branch and
then goes back to the loop again and
then after you get to the end this is
all working in decimal arithmetic has a
string in and you can see it's sort of a
see like our syntax at the right there
in the comments but but you know it's a
seven instruction loop and designed so
that each instruction except the except
the branch to the beginning of the loop
should should go in one cycle and then
at the end you finish and you go back
and start over again and then take half
of the number again
now the but we also had a okay so then I
hand assembly because I said my
assembler
writing it so I so I hand assembled it
into into binary into hexadecimal and so
the instructions are here in these in
these places with the comments at the
right and and remember MX instructions
are very simple because that they have
four bytes the first fight is the
operation code like c1 at the operation
code and FA is would be p fa would be p
base and so c1 would be the or immediate
instructions go on so it was it wasn't
hard to handle symbol this this stuff
and and then we put in a date and
there's a table here that that that has
a table of what's what's half of each
byte and so then then in order to get
the program started we have to load the
context and so on and so on so the very
beginning of the program I'll show you
is the way the loading routine gets gets
things off the ground by by doing a mix
of unsaved instruction which means take
a context though you know all the
registers and and go into and and and
put them all out of memory and into the
real registers and then and then we're
ready to then we're ready to begin the
program then there's a configuration
file and let me show you that so that
would be no let's I I think I used to I
used Prime's Duncan see I use the same
configuration for this program that they
did for for primes this program was
really later so but this is typical of
the kind of things that you can
configure in this simulator so here we
say ma'am address time memory time
memorizing this how many cycles does it
take to spend an address to the physical
address in memory and memory bus and how
many cycles does it take if you want to
read how many cycles before you get
before you get the the data how many
how wide is the memory bus here in this
ticket were taking 16 bytes at a time
here I commented these lines out because
I found a bad bug in my branch
prediction mechanism on Monday I have to
I didn't have time to fix it before
today but I have but one of the things
that you want to do on a machine like
this is to is to do the best possible
job of predicting when a branch is going
to be taken and and I have a general
mechanism that I know I can fix but it
doesn't work at the moment so I
commented ease out but it also allows
you to to base the decision on the next
branch based on combination of where you
are where is the instruction that's
branching and what's in the past history
of branches before this the current one
and then you can also say how there's
also a number of bits that you in your
in your prediction table here are used
in the follow-up to okay so then Memphis
is not important here you know it's
important to gain speed because the
memory is is so slow it's important to
gain speed by putting the recently used
parts of memory into caches and there
are miss particular there are in this
particular case the three caches all the
caches are optional accepted caches for
translation from virtual addresses but
here I'm using I'm using optional cache
so I haven't a secondary cache which has
64 bytes to a in each cache block and
five and twelve sets with four in each
set this is 4-way associative cache and
and it takes two cycles to to find out
whether something's in the cache or not
and to get it the D cache has a smaller
block size and has smaller sets this is
for data and I caches for instructions
and and also has a victim and has a
so-called victim buffer which means that
if you throw something out of the cache
you know in this case I'm keeping two of
them just in case that they're going to
be needed this is not a these are these
have no associativity given so that
means that they're directly mapped
caches with only one one thing we said
all of these things per follow the
caches can be can be specified and also
including the the so-called victim
replacement policy there's a I can tell
you that what pseudo LRU means for those
of you who are know this sort of thing
can you get my pad on that screen the
the pseudo LRU for 4-way associative
cache is something that was used in one
in some Intel machine and it generalizes
to to any power of two so let me show
you what would be like for an eight-way
associative cache although I don't know
if anybody's ever built one of these
it's - it's it's not it's a little bit
expensive in hardware - to keep track of
exactly which was the least most
recently used block and the second most
recently used block and so on
so instead they but let's imagine
they're they're eight blocks but what
you sort of want is that if you've used
the block you don't want to you don't
want to take it out of the cache you
want to say this is a good lock the key
so so this the pseudo LRU scheme Oh true
LRU scheme would say every time you use
a block you you put it at the end of the
line and and you take it out of where it
is and put it at the end of the line and
you keep on doing this and you are and
have to remove a block you take from the
from the front of the line the pseudo
LRU is it is simpler he's only what
Aranea see is 8 blocks and into a tree
and hazard has routing information where
you have a pattern of bits zeros or ones
on each on each node of the tree let me
just give it a random example here
telling you whether you want to go to
the left or to the right when when
you're and in order to find the one that
you're going to remove so this case
would say zero says go to the left one
says go to the right go to the right so
the next one to be removed would be this
one following this this routing
information zero is left one is right
but now when you use a block you set all
of this to go the other way
so suppose I now use this block so that
says ok so then I'm going to change this
bit to a 1 so it'll always go into there
I'm going to change this bit to a zero
and I'm going to change this bit to a 1
so that this block will be it'll be hard
to to to evict this block next until all
three of these bits of change so this is
the idea of pseudo LRU it's you know and
with the simulator we can find out
whether you know whether that behave so
any better than random choice or any
better than then a true LRU and so on
and so there's lots of different of
parameters that's edible here I defined
the the units and and a nice unit is
defined by 256 bits saying which opcodes
it will support and so in this
particular case this one doesn't doesn't
you know that doesn't do any of the
floating points and then it starts doing
add and subtract and so on and it
doesn't do the lois stories which are
here and here's a load store unit which
does the load stores and another one
another one who's a multiplier unit
which picks up the multiply instructions
while floating-point in fixed point
escape because the divider unit
floating-point unit picks up the other
floating point this is just but but any
any combination of things could be used
you could have one unit that's just good
at shifting and taking an in or
here you can say how many instructions
can be dispatched and every cycle
committed every
psycho fits in every cycle you can say
how big the fish buffer is and so on how
inside of the reach of the reorder
buffer there's there's a certain number
of temporary values that are called the
rename registers and spots for storing
and so you so that depending on how much
packet we want you can set these things
describe for each cache whether or not
it's it's right around or right
allocated when you have a Miss do you
want to do you want to evict something
else for puff from the cache or do you
want to or you just want to send a thing
on on to the next level of the hierarchy
right back or right through another
possibility so all of these all of these
you know you can see that that the sort
of not not ending list of possible
things that are Hardware the implementer
can choose between and very difficult to
understand the trade-offs between these
things
we probably not to mention the cost that
some of these things involved with a
simulator like this you can you can try
all kind of all kind of combinations
even ones that you don't know how to
build you know a lot of these things
that I that I that I simulate I really
have no idea if it's even possible to do
at hardware
you know least recently used caches
hukou that are that are 16 way set
associative with with 4 simultaneous
read ports or something like this but
you can find out if if if they you know
if they really save you and and you can
run it on on programs and see if it
actually it actually makes a tremendous
performance and increase or not if it
does well you probably figure out a way
to build it otherwise you'll know that
you know you hope you'll say oh and I'm
good I don't have to figure out how to
do it so this isn't this poor thing from
the right buffer and this says that the
that we keep things five cycles in the
right buffer hoping that that's
something else will one of go in the
same location before we actually decide
to go to this example of parameters I'll
show you another quickly this Prime's
and this one is it's similar but it but
we added a couple of a I'll use has for
Al use and anything I want to show you
at the bottom here we define the the I'm
doing this so we defined that the
division it is going to take six stages
in a pipe the six pipeline stages ten
cycles each and so sixty instead of
sixty steps all in one in one place so
that means that that there are six
places where people can be working on
partials parts or parts of the divides
see if this if this speeds programs up
to have a divider with 6 which is
pipeline in this way I could have made
it 61 or or I could have made it you
know one followed by 59 or anything but
all these but all of the instructions
that that are potentially time-consuming
a floating-point multiply even shifts
you can you can specify the the running
time and and to what extent things are
pipeline so this is a configuration part
now when I run my simulator called M mix
I have a config file first in a program
file afterwards so I say M mix for
example halves dot mmm can see well
actually I use primes did nine
and the program file was have my ex and
so now to get started I have a I have
something called de which which is for
debugging this is just to get going on
until I get my from my assembler and
loading the team working then I have
another thing called k4 Cluj which is
just for this lecture but D and K are my
initials so and this prints out the the
the units and the number of stages in
the unit as a hint to Robert and Chris
now I can I can say you know do a
thousand cycles or so of course
something like that but later but let me
let me just show you the pipeline pieces
show what's in the pipeline so at the
beginning that's Mike my closure or was
it the closure of the D I think it was
the D that did this to put into the pot
it put into the fetch buffer something
that would get that would get will
bootstrap the program the important
thing is this unsafe instruction here
which says the first two inspections put
put something into register zero and the
second one says unsafe starting at the
address in register zero and then we go
to the contents of register F four which
is the way the program is going to start
so at the beginning we you know we have
to boost absolutely so you have to get
going and and fill all the registers
with stuff from memory and then go
I says instruction pointer is waiting
for dispatching and so if I if I said
verbose but to print everything out and
do one cycle you can see that what
happened at cycle zero
it runs the right it runs a program that
looks and sees if there anything in the
right buffer which it doesn't find
anything and then it's easy to apply you
know if we're ready to fetch anything it
isn't because the instruction pointer
isn't in there so then we scheduled
something for ALU one an instruction
that increases register l2 one because
you can't put anything in register zero
and
we have one local register this is a
technicality but anyway this happened
and so it issued the first instruction
and and we left instructions in the
textbox the next cycle does you know I'm
not going to take you through this this
whole program but I wanted to show you
something how the simulator works so it
has to check something is it issued this
set instruction which which is setting
the value of register zero and then in
the reorder buffer now we have two
instructions now this is this is the
information that I gave to Robert and
Chris a trace of this for two thousand
steps and showing showing what the
simulator did you know in the future it
course it's simpler if if we just plug
in there because there's hooks in my
simulator and there and they're similar
they're there visualization routines
could go could go directly from the
simulator but at the moment it was
certainly much much more convenient
since we're changing everything all the
time is to work from stored log files of
what happens if I if I set for both to
zero it's not going to print some and
now I can now say go to thousand steps
and it goes to thousand steps you know
it doesn't take any time and I can look
at for example the D cache and the D
cache will show me that they leave the
values that I said these stylish men
show me only to the values that are that
haven't been stored in lower levels of
hierarchy neither the things that have
actually been written out so in this
particular case I've written out the
numbers zero zero zero zero zero zero
one nine three zero seven and so on and
if I wanted to see the entire d cache it
would have had you know other other
things in it that that that had been
loaded in okay any questions on this you
get the idea yep
it's the that he's fetching -
okay the best buffer is things that have
been fed that that are ready to to be
dispatched and so it goes from the
current instruction so let's take a look
at fetch properly so actually the zeros
here are our fake it's usually this is
usually the address listing so let me
give you a better example turn on
verbose mode again and later what
happened okay
and now let me let me run another
thousand cycles what the heck
this will you'll be able to go and see
the specs buffer let's see let's go to
cycle 1200 mm that's right this is a
slightly brain-damaged emags
so like did I say 20 20 100 okay so here
now we can start looking at fetch buffer
so the first buffer here has two
instructions in it from 10 20 and 1024
okay each instruction four bytes long
and and these are instructions that are
waiting to be issued so at the next time
we would we would issue this load byte
instruction and this if you know unless
unless they you know there's no unit
ready to take it and so what
here it is in fact issued at this point
okay and then then it leaves the fetch
buffer and now has only the probable
branch instruction in instruction
pointer now is is 1 0 0 C you see this
that means that the probable branch was
an instruction that the this simulator
peeks ahead at the fetch buffer even
though it issues only one instruction on
a cycle it also it also looks at the
next one to see if it's a if it's going
to change control gives it and gives it
a head start so that is the grant if if
the branch did occur we
actually lose it we don't actually lose
so this at this point though the fetch
spot fetch but you didn't fetch them
10:28 because it is notes that the
should go next into the other place okay
dad you should answer your question now
let's take a look at that trace and
again and see what happens so now now if
we went back to the beginning of this of
this program we've seen though you'll
see how it started up down so a cycle 0
it has these four instructions in the
fetch buffer set into unsaved and go so
I'll change it to fast and and we'll see
so it'll start the first cycle so so now
the unsaved sits there for a while the
unsaved generates a whole bunch of
instructions into the load store unit
because we have to say we have two
unsaved the context in fact you know
it's it's at least fourteen octa bytes
of information because to get going and
and up to a more than almost 300 if you
save that large large context it takes a
while it looks like it's stalled now but
in fact what's happening is look look
down here you see the main memory is
lighted up that means that the memory is
is locked and the memory is actually
feeding and and and the S cache is
lighted up to that's why you see it in
the step here to that that value you see
these thing at the bottom of the script
that means that the memory you know the
bottom line is this red line from memory
and then the caches are the S caches
yellow D cache will be will be blue when
you see it in the eye cache green the
main memory is is busy now I hope you
finish but the s cache to stop filling
and now the D cache is going to feel ok
so now we we got to get the information
into the into the into the data cache in
order to load it into a register and
then
that was good but that was only 32 bytes
and so we have to do it again the S
cache actually got 64 bytes and so the D
cache will anyway it takes a while and
that's what all of this stuff at the
beginning is getting getting all that
stuff out of memory and and so so we
have to spit here you know 10 10 cycles
just to read 16 bytes out of memory
that's so that's what that's what
happens at this point and then the
unsaved have filled up for the reorder
buffer with six Lord instructions and
they're sitting here in the load story
on it in the first day in the second
stage they're there pounding on the D
cash saying is this please give me this
this data in the first stage they're
saying you know give me a second stage
to go into I'm stalling here because I
can go in the second stage and say give
me this address and and so things will
of ok I can I can I can I can move
faster here past this until we get to
the next stage and when the program is
about to start so let's go ahead so I'm
saved is still happening all this time
and it gets the boring after a while but
in fact this is what this is what
happens in machines you have to realize
you know we don't think about it's going
to writing a program that that it takes
a long time to get to get going at the
beginning fortunately that point that's
only one and so 225 cycles I mean if
we're doing if we're running at 225
megahertz it has only been one one
second so a microsecond yeah yeah okay
so here it's so unsafe come on come on
go on save this time we're doing the go
instruction now it has to go in until
the I cache to watch the I casually laid
up here
okay so finale I - is being filled and a
memory is now reading into the s cash
from a different place now it's reading
from the place where the instructions
were before that it was reading from the
place for the day that was okay and so
then it goes through this this this long
dormant phase here you see that in order
to get the instruction so then we then
we get finally into the program itself
and and and when the program is is going
it still it it still has the memory is
still busy we haven't actually been able
to write anything yet and so things are
building up in the reorder buffer these
are instructions that have the ones that
are bright light bright lighter here
have completed their operation they're
no longer in a functional unit if the
functional unit here is is you know the
store by destruction is what it's
probably waiting for it's waiting for a
place because you can't store a bite
without having reading what the other
bytes were in the word that you're
eating or that you want to store into so
it's taking a while to before it can do
the store bike we should get something
up into the D cash in a minute yeah
there comes from the D cash so pretty
soon we should be able to hit to see
something in the right buffer oh I'll
advance this don't need 20 cycles no now
you see in the right buffer this zero
here well it started with one and it and
should and shouldn't make this up are we
still going No so it should store a five
here and then we should but main memory
still is still locked so it so we're
still bringing stuff up as soon as yeah
as soon as I get to this to this store
bite here that's going to store the 52.5
and then but notice we got the reorder
buffer really full of stuff here this is
now and because this guy it's waiting
for this guy soon as this guy is done
then it's going to commit or be
graduated things are now things are
going to start happening so you watch
them move out of the reorder buffer in
and under the color somebody here the
hell what are the colors okay it's a
Friday lighting that means that it's
already out of the functional unit
otherwise it's the color from the
functional unit so the so the green
would come from a load store and a light
green for my ALU in this particular case
we're gonna have another color for
dividing in the friends again example
and and gray means so it means it's it
sitting here will be a grayish green or
light gray so so here you see then they
is a solid dark green at this point
because it was all a load store and it
was a light green here because it's all
ALU and here was the mixture of the two
we had a whole bunch of load store mixed
up while we were waiting for the perfect
for the cash okay see this is let it up
here 1 2 0 1 2 2 5 point 0 1 2 5 so
that's in the right buffer we've just
computed 1 8 goes off of the law well in
fact that they parsed the log file and
we won't have time we won't have time
today but you know it would be nice it's
good you know if we had extra time for
certain you know I could go through the
origin see what what parameters do you
want how many registers do you want and
comment you know how big a reorder
buffer how much fetch buffer and
everything and then we could you know we
could do it and it would only take three
or four minutes to set it all up and
make it work but I have other demos that
are free that are pre-canned which I
think will give us the same kind of
information but you can play with this
endlessly it's a wonderful toy in fact
we would often write programs and we had
no idea which was going to come out and
then we would see what we thought was
the bottleneck and so I said oh yeah
the program is starved you need some a
bigger fresh buffer I increase the size
of the fish buffer did nothing because
it turned out that that the bottleneck
was really because the fetch buffer had
to be cleared because of the branch
instruction but now I'd like to show you
a bird yeah go ahead
it is possible to describe the situation
around several execution unit capable to
execute the same instruction thoughts
there is different timing for different
number of cycles yeah I'm not sure I
quite understand you have several
instruction it's a cutie it's working on
the same instruction in the unit yeah
one is capable to execute a vision for
50 cycles and another one or say longer
okay yeah right now I
I haven't specialized that I haven't
specialized it that way I have only one
table entry in my config file for for
floating point multiplication for
example I that that would be not hard to
take not hard to add but that but at the
moment it's it's not that general huh
and you know I I don't even when I say
that a shift left is going to take the
same time as a shift right okay I got
another example where I remember I
showed you this this configuration file
where we had extra a I'll use and and
also divided with with with six units
and then I also increase the fetch
buffer size to ten and I wrote this task
program for that let's so let me show
you let me show you that
double click on it okay now this program
go back to Emacs what I did for this
program is
if I I repeated the loop my double I
doubled the loop remember the loop used
to be seven instructions long one two
three four five six seven
anyway the probable branch nonzero so
now I changed it to a branch zero
instead of pile of branch non zero and I
repeated the same seven instructions
again that's just called unrolling the
loop once I didn't do anything fancy
about about interleaving the loops I
just copied the movement again that's
the only change I made to the program
but we're running now with if the config
file that has some lines uncommitted our
see I added a to a I'll use but the main
thing is right here dispatch max three
commits max three means that that's just
a super scalar now we can do three
instructions at a time on it on a clock
cycle and I gave the fetch buffer size
of ten so now let's let's take a look at
this guy here I'm so you see the fish
buffer here is 10 and I now have 4a I'll
use and it's gonna start out with the
same boring stuff at the beginning but
having you know the memory is going to
take the same a lot of time to load that
stuff up and you're gonna sit there and
waiting and then and then for a for one
or two cycles will go zing and and and
be able to do the things out but then
we'll still be waiting for the memory
again so it doesn't really help the hell
with the superscalar until we get going
into the into the program itself so
let's start let's let's start let's go
to a two part in into the middle of the
program here with and start executing
now with with this super scalar version
that's buffer seems to be empty okay so
I bet so here we you see we you want me
to go a little floor so here so I can I
can go even story up receipt but first
look at the reorder buffer about half
the time you'll see three and three
things leaving the reorder buffer right
every saw at every time that's the
payoff if you can if three things can be
committed or if the three things can be
issued or if you know and are committed
then then then work we're using the
superscalar feature of the of the things
so it's going here and going into the
ALU and you see the region see the gray
slots this one is waiting for something
to finish we came out of the out of the
lowers closed or you know kind of a neat
set here these two come in if they go
out okay this is this from a small
program we can see we can see
you know how much speed is the advantage
we're getting we're not getting a
effective three but but it is working
and I'll let you watch a little bit more
notice the fetch buffer is empty right
at this point that's because we did get
to the end of the fourteen instructions
then we had to them then we had to start
over then I had to feel fetching again
and since we're dispatching three things
at a time we probably should have have
more than duplicated the loop but if I
had repeated the loop a few more times
then I then then this pausing for the
fetch buffer would almost never been
necessary I think but I haven't tried it
I have to hand assemble this darn thing
every time I mean so so III do placated
a little poney twice since I'm typing in
the heck to death and stuff next week
I'll have an assembler that make this
make this real fast
okay so that's medium speed of the of
that routine question let me show you
the comparison of the two
yeah so so here are the two that the
timeline or this I'm still running
that's interesting stop it no it doesn't
stop no I see just took a little out for
it to get okay so you can see you can
see the two you can see how much you
know how much we're gaining on it the
with the with without the superscalar
we're getting one Ron Ron Ron Ron each
one takes one more cycle because the
number gets one more digits long every
time you take half of it and here you
see it's going much faster okay now the
other demo I want to show you is what is
for prime number
so the first example fruit of a
decent-size program that I have in our
the computer program and use the program
to calculate the first 500 prime number
and this is it so naturally I'll
probably you retain that same that same
example in the in with M mix as I had as
I had used for me and and so I rewrote
it you know in the assembler and and now
we're going to show you two versions
three three versions one of them is the
is where you issue one instruction at a
time and you wait and the divide is not
pipelined and and so it waits 60 cycles
for every division now you know how to
cut it how to calculate prime numbers
there's many ways to do it but this is
the most obvious way we start out we say
that 2 is prime and in fact we even
stated three is prime and then we have
to test and we're going to go through
odd numbers when you try 5 7 9 11 13 and
so on and and so is 5 prime well we
tried dividing it by the prime numbers
odd prime numbers we already know so we
divide 5 by 3 our remainder is not 0 so
if I is not a multiple of 3 it looks
good
in fact you know that's all we have so 5
must be prime
7 divided by 3 the remainder is it is
not 0 we don't even have to divide 7 by
5 because we find out that 7 divided by
3 is already less than 3 and that means
that the divisor was it was bigger than
the square root of the number we're
trying and anything that's not prime
it's going to have something that's less
than the square root of it that divides
it so we only have to divide until the
quotient is is less than the remainder
or greater than the main or one of those
two as soon as we get isn't really
divided by numbers that the quotient is
smaller than then they then the divisor
then then we've tested enough enough to
see that it's prime so that's the idea
of this algorithm it's simply if we're
trying to decide a 21 25 is probably
divided by 3 and then by 5 3 whoops it
zero emic says uh has one thing I wish
all computers had in medicine the divide
and remainder are obtained at the same
time on other computers you do a
division almost logins I know that where
you want to know the quotients you also
want to know the remainder in the next
line of your program or so uh it seems
silly when you have such an expensive
instruction you already had the
remainder to have to calculate it again
but that's the but that's the way most
machines seem to work in fact a lot of
machines don't even do the vision in
Hardware anymore but that's another
story
so with M mix we have the quotient in
the remainder of one of them appears in
the special register sign this is this
is the is the prime program thanks Thank
You Robert you see it starts out with
the same bootstrapping idea and then but
when it gets going it's a little
different now than before because it's
building up a whole bunch of stuff in
the reorder buffer let's let's go there
and see that looks like it's a little
bit interesting enough to get get into
this program so we first we had a dead
time waiting for the I cashed in to get
some instruction in here let's let's
look in here we're starting to to think
about prime numbers okay the memory is
is filling the s cache during this time
but we can we can start seeing it's
what's happened now it's a little
different than before because because
there is going to be a divided
instruction coming at the moment I'm
waiting for a load however I'm trying to
load something that's B the next
instruction is going to be increase and
load Y so this will be a trial divisor
that we were trying to load so we could
do a division instruction division
instruction should should should come
along pretty soon let me go let me go on
so we're building up instructions in the
reorder buffer that have already been
processed but they're all
they're hanging on on this this load or
store instruction up here yeah that's
right I'm 20 on the trader
okay and trace the store so so I can
jump ahead to 350 to move out too much
bro now here you see in the right buffer
2 is prime 3 is prime even in
hexadecimal
- ok and and the division is lit up here
so 60 cycles later this division will be
you know this purple guy will be none
now in the in the reorder buffer by the
way in my program I thought it was
important to you know writing a literate
program you want to be able to describe
the algorithm in interesting terms in
that and I and I had to check also that
the the architecture of a mix was was
going to work properly in cases of
interruption and so on and I I needed a
name for things that were that were at
the beginning at that you know that that
are ready to graduate ready to commit
and things that were that were fairly
new and I decided that I would say that
this was the hot seat up here the top of
the reorder buffer is called the hot
seat and at the bottom this is the cool
end so everything is cool when it starts
and it gets warmer and warmer the longer
it sits in the reorder buffer and you
know the you know the air conditioning
is a little tricky in these stuff in
these chips and so uh and so the
students also made this that's why
transitions from blue to red here in but
the guy in the hot seat is this divide
instruction and it's going to wait for
the for the divide to finish even if I
had an interrupt at this point it would
wait for the divide to finish but I did
take take the account that a
floating-point remainder instruction
sitting in the hot state would would be
interrupted because that floating-point
remainder might take several thousand
cycles in the earth case okay things are
going are happening now even though this
division is going on not
depends on the result of the division
for a while and and and so you're able
to get this now you see these vertical
lines there that's when when something
goes in the right buffer so that shows
the time when we find the prime so so
here so we're gonna find five is prime
here probably or seven is prime here I
mean and then this will be eleven this
will be thirteen this will be seventeen
twenty twenty three twenty nine I don't
know why 31 I don't know now we'll be
able to see that but anyway this is the
idea of what happens when you when
you're when you've got an algorithm that
unfortunately has to wait for the result
of this divide I have to see if the
remainder is zero before I know what
what before I can go on next even though
I've done the next instructions they're
sitting there waiting to school you know
wait this is a get instruction which
says get the remainder register into
into a normal register afterwards
there's going to be a test for less than
then an increment instruction and I'm
putting a parallel branch instruction
but those are still sitting in the fetch
buffer because the less the LSS
instruction has to go into an ALU so so
a I'll use were both busy okay something
happened there will see something in the
right buffer momentarily I hope yep
there it is seven we just found seven is
prime okay you know okay let's let's go
ahead let's go ahead here and take a
look at the right buffer it's going into
the next the next byte now I'm sorry I
wanted to see it when the right buffer
is still is still active so at this
point we've just found that something is
prime okay you see it's a little hard to
recognize these Prime's maybe and
hexadecimal is B it's 11 D you guys know
your hexadecimal 13
I've been practicing hexadecimal wines
women's when I'm swimming you know
instead of counting my skills you know I
go eight nine ABCDEF you know no no no
it's actually the hard thing is after
you get to after after 70 F then the
next thing no I'm sorry
after 90 if the next thing would sound
like 80 because a and eight you know
would both say you know so I have I have
so I so I say a as an or so so I so I go
9 o ABCDE F 10 11 12 you know I've 18
you know BTC teen DT I'm serious about
it it's important okay so this thing is
still going again but let's look at the
at the version that has some crimes X
this is you see now the divide has this
ten cycle pipeline like this okay so
let's take a look and see you see how
that how that looks like when we're
doing we're getting in okay now here we
actually have two division instructions
in here so so the a and because we also
have another X a I'll use the ones
waiting for the remainder of the first
division and so he starts to start going
and and it's waiting for the result of
that one okay so that so that allows
some things to complete a fetch buffer
gets you know gets the move stuff out
and and what happened to the other
divine as I was supposed to take ten
cycles what happened
wait a minute
this above why are we doing here go
backward no no no what did yeah this is
a computer we better the new divide
algorithm you know what 1/0 doesn't even
take six cycles I think it goes right
into the it goes right
oh wait that's true that was it divide
by zero why was it dividing by zero yeah
yeah but I mean oh did I is this the one
right where I've actually tripled up the
loop okay then let me see this is
Prime's excuse I don't think it was well
we'll have to see why it divided by zero
I guess okay something has to go wrong
in every demo but where was like when I
divide by zero it depends on whether the
divide by zero interrupts is enabled and
so I didn't enable it so it just sets a
bit in the in the arithmetic exception
register and it returns the it actually
returns the remainder equal to the
original number and a quotient of zero
which is which is kind of reasonable
because the remainder I mean like if you
and the quotient is zero but that but
that has the right effect actually the
quote but by quizzes it it says the
thing is it's actually it's actually a
win but now see there's two there's two
things in dividing in here right this is
a cycle five twenty five so let me uh
let me stop it and look at cycle 5 25
the Emacs sorry I got to get he next up
here don't I okay so this is Prime's
Oh 525 this slow machine it's a it's
safe I actually have many many more than
2000 cycles on here so this is thirteen
megabyte file
any questions while we're waiting let me
play I wanted to say what ok cycle 525
so it says it is God in the reorder
buffer has a division instruction
dividing 9 by 3 and dividing 9 by 3 and
it says yeah and then the other division
instruction is dividing 9 by 5 oh
because oh that's right very good
so after it finds out the remainder is 0
then this is speculative execution so
that so the division so second division
wasn't really necessary
and it could be decommitted it could be
d issued and so so how do you actually
do animate to be issuing let's watch it
so there's a way to actually think
things go out of the reorder buffer at
the bottom if there if you find out that
that that's something in the middle of
the reorder buffer with a branch
instruction that went the unexpected way
then you empty the reorder buffer from
the bottom up and the reason is that you
have to undo the data structure in fact
the reorder buffer is it has to be has
to be tricky there could be a lot of
things refer to the same register in
that you know in a reorder buffer let me
let me fill you out I'll see if we can
get this on the screen
a buffer like here suppose that
there might be there might be many
instructions in here which the
this instruction might say is that
registered zero to something or other
you know some another one says register
zero to something another one says
register zero for instructions might
might be affecting register zero in here
all the instructions in between all the
instructions from here on refer to this
register zero but all the instructions
in here refer to this one all
inspections in here refer to that one
and so on so that's why they have what
they call rename registers rename
register holds the the everything in
here is pointing to the rename register
for this result and so on so so the when
you when you when you do instruction you
want to do it from the bottom so that so
that things will know now start pointing
to this rename register okay and as I
was writing this simulator it taught me
an important lesson that that writing is
similar like this with lots of
parameters and lots of possibilities in
the config in the configurations was act
was in some way I much more confident
about it than if I were writing a
simulator for an actual machine that had
only a certain number of LSU's and happy
use and things like this because I had
to think big I had to think of a reorder
buffer that was a thousand lines long
and and I had to think of cases like
this which would never occur in a you
know I'm you know in practice on a on a
real machine maybe only a certain
register might ever never be able to be
used more than twice or something like
that and the hardware wouldn't have to
implement the general scheme but in
order to know that my algorithms were
correct I had to make him work in in the
case where you had a huge number of
possibilities in this meant that I that
I was that was much easier to visualize
the general case if I was thinking small
all the time I would be either you know
every weekend I was on another bug oh I
forgot this could have been bigger and
so so there's a great advantage actually
in implementing something more general
than you actually will ever
because because that it forces you to
think and makes it actually intuitively
clear what the what the what the what
the hard cases are that you have to
handle I say I say I got a D issue five
things or whatever it is no no all right
what I do yeah well what I do is though
I before I commit anything more I I go
from the bottom so so so the general
cycle says is there anything to do issue
then the issue is there anything to
commit then commit but but but priority
goes to D issuing because I think I want
to get you know I want to get things
things going and I and I have to undo
the renames in reverse order
that's but but the information was there
and it was you know instead of letting
it not so it's a trade-off as to whether
I want to or whether I want to let it
bubble all the way up the top but I
wanted to to start the fetcher going at
the right address as soon as I could and
so so that's the way I implemented it in
certainly all the way through the
simulator there were there were
trade-offs but there were decisions like
that designed this one was the one that
I thought I chose what I got saying it's
the it's the right that travels along
with the reorder buffer I the arithmetic
exception possible interruption or even
interrupt if you can interrupt occurs
you still don't know if it's going to be
real because it might not get to the hot
seat but but things like the things like
the instruction location are carried
along with it can be implicit of course
in high
but in software you might as well the
whole thing okay so see crime what am i
doing xxxx right now
this this or last this last example is
for the it is where I I again have this
divided unit but I and the same specs as
before but I changed all right I changed
my program so that it sort of doubles up
the loop again not not not quite as it's
actually simpler I divide by three by
three numbers at a time so suppose
you're trying to check if say 2029 is
prime it would divide by three five and
seven then it would test to see is the
is the quotient quotient less than the
divisor then it would divide by the next
three and then it would say is the
course list and divisor this means that
there are fewer instructions in between
for for loop bookkeeping and you know
fewer times that I'm actually checking
the quotient against the divisor yes I
can do more unnecessary device but you
see the pipeline with this pipeline it
actually doesn't call it because because
the other the unnecessary divides are
see you know I sort of math so so oh
yeah interesting trade-offs are going on
with like for example here I have three
things now in the divide in the divide
queue and every ten cycles they will
advance and but but you know if I had to
divide by ten things before before
before finding out and at this time I'll
divide by we're finding out something is
prying I'll divide by twelve now I round
up to the next higher multiple of three
but if it's not prime I cut off right
away anyway because the right the
remainder will be found to be zero
the remainder will be found to be zero
while it's sitting here in the reorder
buffer and it will okay it'll it'll
squash the other device so I guess it's
not quite as fast so now here I have
only one division going on that one that
one disappeared for not to be
unnecessary because the result of
another test pretty soon we'll fill up
with another his life see we're issuing
three instructions at a time so so now
you see the period the periodic pattern
of the pink here are the divided how
many things we have in the how many
divides are are pending often three and
the dark green are the are the things
that are waiting to be loaded there are
trial divisors and the light green are
the trivial bookkeeping operations and
the branches tests and things like that
and every vertical line is when I found
a prime and there will be another glitch
when I found a non prime okay so you can
you know before we before we saw this we
had no real idea what was going to
happen with the outlet the other and you
know it's Mike looking say oh the fetch
popper is full now maybe we maybe we
share a bigger fetch buffer because we
had a bigger fresh buffer it would start
fetching more instructions after but
that wouldn't do it do a bit of good as
far as getting these guys on Jam because
it's waiting on this divide up here and
it would okay so now I just want to
compare the three of the three prime
strip charge so that you can serve any
questions before I flip this one down
crime so no I'm sorry what is that the
CP is that way what yeah okay
CP e okay so this is so at the top was
the case where I where I tripled up the
loop and divided by three things at a
time here's where I'm dividing bike by
only one thing at a time but I still
have this super scalar effect where and
and you know several device can be going
at one and the and the other one was
this guy which is the case where the
divide unit was was taking hole 60
cycles from the non pipeline of course
it's very difficult to pipeline a divide
unit but I'm not saying that there is an
easy way to pipeline a divide so that
you could do ten ten ten ten
well if you could this is what you would
this is how much you would gain until
you see the friends of hopping along
somewhat faster not six times faster
though the best way to make it six times
faster is to figure out how to do a
divide in ten cycles
so anyway this is a this is something
that amazingly the demo didn't break so
far and so we got to give a big hand to
Robert and Chris and the other thing I
wanted to announce is that during the
next few weeks I'm going to make so be
making some critical decisions about you
know things about the FMX
as I as it comes out and I so I want to
have people to bounce ideas off over
into challenge to my my opinions and so
on so I'm planning to have a gathering
at my house on Saturday at least one or
two Saturday one Saturday and probably
the 27th of this month so if people know
this is only for people who are really
seriously going to volunteer and you
know one to not not just you know to be
there as a observer but actually as a as
a you know somebody willing to put time
into into helping me get the MX you know
before I make too many mistakes but but
if if you are interested this will be
probably arranged through the M mix
masters home page which is page
anyway that's coming up in about three
weeks to you and Buster I have a second
question what make the best answer but
the second question is there are you
for instance myself with very long
construction work and as I understand
the main Western design of music news
right now is to get as much as possible
of real estate on the cheap and to
utilize to make it working all together
yet must be it more Mohammed so how
stressful is your model for instance we
will be able to cover things like the
said you know so much that this kind of
thing so I addressed some of that in in
the previous lecture where my my main
goal is to is to have a good model that
someone can can learn and enjoy
programming in and not to not to get the
maximum speed for all applications so I
want a general purpose computer that's
that's uh that reflects the risk
methodology but not to be the best for
Fourier transforms or or you know some
kind of some kind of thing where it
where a special applicant you know this
is number crunching calculations so I'm
not trying to have the fastest computer
for for particular applications that are
high economic interests I'm most
interested in having a nice clean
understandable realistic model of a
color computer before before they get
ugly
so long now as far as simulation
languages go you know I actually also
had a simulation language called Sol
it's a simulation oriented language
which I withdrew when I learned about
similar one because I felt similar was
it was a big advance on it though which
you know stimulus 57 actually what was
after simular one but similar one was
was sufficiently better than my Sol that
I said why should I work on Sol anymore
and that was in similar one and 667 was
the beginning of object-oriented
programming you know now how
you know with my knowledge of simulation
I still would would have done this
particular simulator the way I did i but
I'll publish it in somebody can do what
I did in this program without you know
using using some other other tools then
that's great but but but I didn't see
how I was going to actually apply that
object technology to actually do what I
wanted to do because I had to cut I had
to
well you could take my you know this
program is in C++ because it's an C but
it doesn't mean that I got anything that
you know I I I wasn't able to use the
library I had to build my own yeah I'm
trying to do to do that by writing as a
literate program which means that people
can understand what I did and but my
attitude sort of is rather than provide
things that are blocks that black boxes
that people plug into other things I
present something that that has open you
know explain what's inside of it and and
you you massage it with your text editor
rather than including that incorporating
as a module that's Mike have us be the
way I you know I approached mathematics
the same way I some people think
mathematics mathematicians are supposed
to to produce theorems and the only
thing is to know the enunciation of the
theorem and the conclusion of the
theorem but to me the important thing is
the proof of the theory
because in practice you have something
that doesn't really fit the hypothesis
is close and and you doesn't give you
quite the results you want but it's
close
and that's what I do with my programs
every cycle so the pipeline so the
functional units each are are either
active or asleep but usually active
they're waiting for something and I
think of the cars in is in it in in the
shop you know if there's you first of
all if the car has to drive next into it
into the the thing on the next block
then I'll the guy on the next block has
to get his car out of there so he might
be stalled because because something in
the next stage is already blocking you
know there's another group of people
Stokes to work on it but if that if
there's not a stall for that reason you
might be saw because you're waiting for
one of your operands you can't add two
numbers until the what the previous one
has been computed but soon as but if
you've got your operands then you
combine on the goes to the next step so
so the the typical I mean you can take a
look at my program but the typical
typical thing says you know it it is
such and such happened it's lesson
touched already do it otherwise wait and
reschedule yourself for it for the next
time and and so you have to wait for
locks in the in the the the these locks
here are when there's competition for
resources and so and and now you can
also have a situation where one of the
instructions in the way in the reorder
buffer is is waiting has locked the D
cache or something like that but it
turns out that instruction was was they
issued on speculation it's not really
necessary and so we have to unlock the D
cache when we
when we cancel that that that thing
that's but the basic cycle is at every
unit of time there's a bunch of coal
routines in the program each core teams
in certain state like the load/store if
you look at my Emacs first thing it
would say show you that exactly here you
see the reorder buffer just wrap around
because we we made a large pot but to
divide it says at the end state equals
to okay
and it's just divided 1 : 4 that means
in the fourth stage of the of the
divided pipeline and it will and the
next one is to get which is that says Z
equals greater than our register R that
means it's waiting for the remainder
register has to go into operand Z from
the and the remainder register isn't
ready yet because their major register
is going to be computed by the divide
instruction now at the next at the next
at the next cycle if it runs the the
right coroutine which is in state 0
which means not you know a sort of
initial State it's and it find nothing
to do so it schedules itself little for
time 527 in the state 0 then that ALU
one is doing this get instruction it
schedules itself for the next time
because of the Z still isn't ready Lu to
schedules itself at the next time you
know either these guys are just sitting
there waiting for the next time and so
so that wasn't a very interesting time
let's go full committee for something so
so I cycle 5 53 53 this this thing this
instruction was was no longer in it was
that it was in the hot seat and no
longer you know in a fetch in a in a
functional unit so it's ready to commit
itself and then we start running the
right instruction again nothing and then
neither do these things and then here we
issue a new instruction F that's sort of
the general general cycle yep is the
spine ever jump forward in increments
greater than not is on it's it's unusual
that's but they can go to sleep so I
think if it says running something and
then like like this running okay running
lu1 it didn't wasn't followed by
scheduling so that meant actually either
went to sleep or it finished in this
case it finished but if something is
going is something is waiting for the D
cash to be filled it goes to sleep and
the D cash pillar wakes it up when on so
so you know that's the technicality but
it doesn't have to come up every every
cycle when somebody will know to wake it
up and this is typical of stimulation
language but this greater detail or yeah
there's different you could you so the D
cash has input and output I mean you
have to put something new into the D
cash and then there's the time when you
flush the D cash down to the S cash or
something like that and the when you're
flushing the deep when you're flushing
the D cash down to the next level of the
hierarchy which either memory or to s
cash then you
then it goes into a special buffer and
that and usually only one thing is being
flushed at a time when but and so it
goes into that special buffer right away
and some and and and usually that's
because you want to replace it with some
new information so when you write into
the D cache you have to usually you take
the information that was previously in
there if you're not just updating it you
have to you have to flush something else
and that goes into this separate buffer
and I and the separate buffer usually
has to it has to be there because you
don't know if somebody else might be
using the s cache of the memory that
wants to that wants to get it so this is
called the victim buffer
I think but usually they don't have two
buffers like that there's a lot of
really interesting code but I was going
around in circles a lot of this stuff
like because I couldn't figure out a
truly elegant way to handle all of the
cases of caches considering all the
possibilities that I can have write
allocate write right around I could have
right back right through and all these
things to be handling them and I can die
and for five or six days I was spinning
and spinning I couldn't think you know I
kept writing new drafts of the program
and tearing it up and see and I was and
finally I decided the only way to do it
is to throw code at the problem you know
write 10 pages of code for each case and
their network but but but you know I
would like to find a truly elegant
mathematical solution to all parts of
this it didn't good thing to be possible
much more each part of it is
understandable by itself but the whole
whole package together as an unavoidable
complexity I think well thank you very
much for listening
you